[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le jeudi 16 février voici le programme
de ce soir alors que les débats prennent
fin demain à l'Assemblée nationale une
cinquième journée de grève nationale
contre la réforme des retraites était au
programme aujourd'hui la mobilisation
s'étend et s'intensifie également dans
les Yvelines ce jeudi une manifestation
s'est tenue à Versailles dans la rue
notamment des pompiers du département
venus exprimer leur mécontentement
contre la réforme la grippe aviaire
est-elle de retour dans les Yvelines non
selon la direction départementale de la
protection des populations qui assure la
surveillance de toute la chaîne
alimentaire si plusieurs mouettes ont
été retrouvées mortes à cause du virus
dans le bassin de la Sourderie à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux fin janvier il
n'y a pas d'inquiétude à avoir les
prennent quand même toutes les
précautions nécessaires nous avons fait
le point avec l'un d'eux et avis à tous
les gourmands dans les Yvelines il est
possible de boire son café dans une
tasse comestible baptisée arzino la
tasse est faite en biscuits épais et
garni de chocolat noir un concept
insolite imaginé par un couple
d'entrepreneurs Kévin et Julie Couvet
leur entreprise est basée à Janville
dans le nord des Yvelines nous sommes
allés à leur rencontre et avec mon
plateau de militaires Vincent Dorival et
Nicolas itin bonsoir alors vendredi 17
mars l'association Solidarité nationale
pour le handicap et les militaires
blessés organisent un gala de charité
pour soutenir des projets au service du
vivre ensemble il s'agit d'une première
édition Vincent dorivel vous avez été
blessé d'un exercice de vos fonctions et
vous Nicolas éteint vous êtes le père
d'un enfant trisomique pourquoi c'était
important pour vous deux de participer
et d'organiser cette soirée
important parce que
la globalité de ce projet en fait est
positif et c'était important pour nous
de faire partie de cet élan en fait ce
nouvel élan voilà qui intègre à la fois
des des associations qui prennent en
charge des blessés de la défense mais
également des gens issus de la société
ce qui fait que ça regroupe voilà c'est
un projet global et qui est cet élan en
fait est important donc pour nous
c'était important d'y participer Nicolas
organiser cet événement donc c'est vrai
que c'est important de regrouper ces
différentes thématiques d'un côté les
militaire mais aussi les familles qui
sont concernées par le handicap de toute
façon et finalement tout se lit et
justement c'est important de mettre tous
ces projets ensemble
pour montrer justement le vivre ensemble
et l'inclusion l'insertion sociale quoi
de ces projets plus en détail tout à
l'heure nous sommes aussi avec
Jean-Claude Pelletier bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes le secrétaire général de
l'association Les Amis du Vieux
Saint-Germain et vous fêtez cette année
les 100 ans de cette association alors
celle-ci a pour but de sauvegarder le
patrimoine de la ville est-ce que vous
pouvez nous présenter en quelques mots
cette association oui alors donc cette
association qui va pas tout à fait
s'entend mais dans un mois
cette association
est a pour but de mettre en valeur
le côté artistique le côté patrimonial
et historique de la ville de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye
ville-royal ville impériale donc il y a
un riche passé et nous avons donc
beaucoup d'adhérents et nous avons donc
beaucoup d'activités à la fois au profit
de ces adhérents mais aussi de recherche
donc
ça fait donc 100 ans ça évoluer il y a
eu un départ tonitruant et puis une
petite baisse un peu avant la Seconde
Guerre mondiale et puis un peu après et
ça fait 25 ans que c'est bien reparti et
maintenant nous avons encore 350
adhérents donc une société une
association solide donc on en parlera
également en détail tout à l'heure une
journaliste de la rédaction de TV 78 est
également en plateau avec nous Gabriel
Gonthier bonsoir bonsoir Mathilde alors
comme d'habitude le jeudi vous allez
nous présenter vos idées de sortie pour
le week-end mais à l'approche des
vacances scolaires d'hiver là vous
attendez un petit peu je vous parlerai
notamment d'une exposition qui se passe
à Versailles c'est l'exposition Louis XV
une exposition qui s'achève dimanche
Mathilde et à cette occasion le château
de Versailles a décidé de la décliner en
exposition nocturne on en parlera dans
la deuxième partie de ce journal oui ce
sera enfin d'émission mais juste avant
je vous propose de jeter un coup d'oeil
à la météo de demain
[Musique]
matin le ciel sera nuageux sur
l'ensemble du département au niveau des
températures il fera environ 11 degrés
du côté de Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan et
10 degrés dans les secteurs de
Versailles et Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi prévoyait quelques averses
à Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans et Versailles
seul le Rambouillet devrait rester au
sexe selon Météo France côté et
température comptez environ 14 degrés
dans le secteur de Mantes-la-Jolie et
Houdan et 13 degrés à Versailles et
Rambouillet et demain nous fêterons la
sainte Alexis le point maintenant sur
les informations du jour dans les
Yvelines avec Michael elle mie d'euros
de larges couloirs plus de strapontin
pour offrir plus de place en heure
creuses et de la couleur la Société du
Grand Paris Alstom vient de dévoiler le
design intérieur des rames de la future
ligne 18 du nouveau métro francilien les
usagers trouveront également des prises
USB des écrans d'information à
l'intérieur des rames ils pourront aussi
bénéficier de la connexion 4G et 5G les
futurs rames pourront transporter 350
passagers conçus dans le cas du Grand
Paris Express la ligne s'étendra sur 35
km entre Orly et Versailles à l'horizon
2030 et desservira trois gares dans les
Yvelines notre chiffre du jour 185 c'est
le nombre de kilomètres de voies qui
seront réservés en Île-de-France pendant
la période des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques 2024 ces axes seront
accessibles aux athlètes et à tous les
membres des délégations olympiques au
secouriste aux journalistes accrédité
c'est portions seront également
réservées aux taxi aux véhicules de
transport en commun dans les Yvelines la
portion de l'autoroute sur la 13 entre
le Chine et Rocancourt et Saint-Cloud
est concerné
a été fermé depuis le 7 juin 2022 la
médiathèque des 7 mars rouvre ses portes
le mardi 21 février les travaux auront
permis une rénovation de l'isolation du
bâtiment une restauration de la façade
et une réorganisation pour valoriser les
collections une fête de réouverture sans
organisée les 15 et 18 mars il y aura du
sport ce weekend avec les quarts de
finale de la Coupe des Yvelines l'équipe
3 demande jouera contre l'équipe 2 de
Conflans Aubergenville recevra l'équipe
3 de Versailles Sartrouville 2 ira défi
Rambouillet Les Mureaux 2 affront oyo 2
les rencontres sont programmées ce
dimanche à 15h il faudra s’armer de
patience ce week-end sur les routes de
la région parisienne avec le début des
vacances d'hiver quelques perturbations
sont à prévoir vendredi Bison Futé voit
orange dans le sens des départs en
Île-de-France il est conseillé de
quitter ou de traverser la région avant
11h samedi le trafic devrait s'améliorer
en Île-de-France mais les conditions de
circulation seront très difficiles si
vous vous rendez vers les stations de
ski dans les Alpes les Vosges ou le Jura
[Musique]
et comme d'habitude si vous voyez une
information qui vous
a près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous
la partager en utilisant le hashtag 7 8
news dans l'actualité également la
mobilisation d'aujourd'hui contre la
réforme des retraites la CGT des
Yvelines a organisé une manifestation à
Versailles le cortège est parti de la
gare des Chantiers et s'est rendu aux
anciens locaux du Medef 78 le reportage
de Céline Charles
ils sont venus nombreux à Versailles
pour dire non à la réforme des retraites
selon la CGT des Yvelines 350
manifestants ont défilé dans les rues
pour le 5e jour de grève et de
mobilisation on sera à la manifestation
à Paris aussi mais c'était de démontrer
ici dans cette ville de Versailles entre
la préfecture le château le Medef et
tous les lieux de pouvoir ici en
Yvelines que le monde du travail en
Yvelines est mobilisé professeur
personnel hospitalier retraitée ou
encore employé territoriaux faisaient
partie du cortège objectif maintenir un
fil revendicatif et s'inscrire dans la
durée elle va pousser nous les petites
gens les gens qui sont cassés au boulot
qui ont une espérance de vie bien moins
grande que
des gens qui ne travaillent pas en
horaires décalé etc qui va nous pousser
à travailler plus longtemps sans doute
parfois mourir au travail ou à avoir des
pensions à moins de riz à cause de la
une forme Touraine et de son
accélération le fait de pouvoir partir
plus tôt c'est une reconnaissance
justement de la pénibilité du travail
c'est des acquis sociaux c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on donne gratuitement
aux gens il y a une cotisation à toute
cotisation qui souvent est plus élevée
il faut que les gens prennent conscience
que si on bloque pas le pays de façon
pourra défiler pendant 10 ans on n'aura
rien puis d'une centaine de pompiers de
plusieurs syndicats ont également fait
le déplacement le gouvernement ils sont
contents de nous appeler sur tous les
théâtres d'opération et à côté de ça
derrière qu'est-ce qu'ils font bah ils
veulent qu'on travaille plus longtemps
et sachant que nous c'est impossible
pour nous à 60 ans vous imaginez bien
que par rapport à toutes les missions
qu'on a bah c'est ultra compliqué d'être
en forme et en bonne santé je vous cache
pas aussi que on fait pas 35 heures à
côté de ça on cumule tous les risques
professionnels qu'il existe quasiment le
texte de loi est examiné jusqu'au
vendredi 17 février à l'Assemblée
nationale mais les syndicats ne comptent
pas s'arrêter là si la prochaine date de
mobilisation et de grève est fixée aux 7
mars prochain à l'échelle nationale une
manifestation aux flambeau est prévue le
vendredi 17 février à Rambouillet
et en parallèle de ces journées de grève
et de manifestations les débuts les
députés continuent de débattre sur la
réforme des retraites à l'Assemblée
nationale mais est-ce qu'il aura un
gagnant dans ce grand face à face auquel
nous assistons entre le gouvernement et
les syndicats pour Véronique Jérôme
maître de conférence à l'Université de
Paris Saclay et spécialiste de Polito
économie cette réforme pourrait ne faire
que des perdants écoutez
[Musique]
tous piégés le politique qui a annoncé
ce qu'il allait faire et qui s'apprête à
faire ce qu'il a annoncé il voit sa
perte de crédibilité faire obstacle à la
réforme des électeurs du second tour
macronistes contrôleur gré les syndicats
pris au piège d'une crise de confiance
malvenue dans une période de crise
économique marquée par le retour de
l'inflation et puis cette francieuse qui
pour partie le pavé pour la première
fois motiver mes résigner pourquoi en
étant arrivé là Emmanuel Macron n'a pas
eu des tas de grâce et si la réforme a
tant de mal à passer c'est qu'elle a été
empruntée au programme de LR en
concurrence pour les voix afin d'élargir
les soutiens cette triangulation acerte
faciliter la victoire le candidat trop
souvent ne fait pas un programme et ne
fait un programme que pour gagner mais
ici Emmanuel Macron veut aussi et c'est
assez rationnel appliqué son programme
il va se piéger s'obligeant à tenir ses
engagements engagements issus d'un grand
écart problématique sauver le système
par réparti sur ce qui est un totem de
gauche mais aussi faire d'inévitable
compromis contre des soutiens de droite
et ceci risque encore d'entamer sa perte
de crédibilité
elle offre deux visages elle se dit en
grande majorité dans les sondages contre
le recul de l'âge de la retraite tout en
reconnaissant la nécessité d'une réforme
une réforme vue sous deux angles un
angle sociotropique ou global ou
l'intérêt général est sous la contrainte
d'un équilibre des comptes et puis un
angle individuel ou égotropique ou
chacun fait de son cas un cas
d'exclusion à la réforme on est comme
prise au piège d'une contradiction qui
ne dirait pas son nom oui à la réforme
si ce sont les autres qui en font les
frais s'ajoute aussi un horizon qui
atteste d'un conflit intergénérationnel
où les actifs d'hier retraitées
d'aujourd'hui sollicite un système par
répartition dû à la solidarité des
actifs inquiets d'aujourd'hui retraitée
demain
il semble pris en tenaille entre agir
fort mais pas trop fort agir fort pour
reconstituer un pouvoir de nuisances
bien utile mais qui s'émoussent alors
même que la réforme est l'arbre qui
cache une forêt de revendication qui
s'exprime en abîme défense du pouvoir
d'achat en tête agire fort pour aussi
corriger cette perte de confiance actée
dans les sondages ceci impose de
maintenir une certaine unité syndicale
mais aussi de donner des gages à sa base
mais il ne faut pas agir trop fort il
faut éviter le piège de nuisances qui
deviendrait contre-productive avec des
actions renouvelées assez inédites
préférant pour leur des manifestations
le samedi aux grèves paralysantes ces
opérations ont de moindre conséquences
en termes de perte de salaire mais
l'objectif est aussi de ne pas perdre le
soutien de l'opinion publique tout en
offrant une certaine résistance d'où les
menaces que l'on entend de bloquer le
pays aujourd'hui car dans un bras de fer
entre syndicat et gouvernement le
premier qui faiblit a perdu
le scénario le plus crédible est que la
réforme va passer votez grâce au piège
tendu au LR ils en rêvaient Emmanuel
Macron l'a fait ils ne peuvent pas la
refuser ils seront le pivot la variable
d'ajustement s'il leur demande son
honorées dans l'opposition mais votant
en force d'appoint de la majorité
relative mais d'autres pièges peuvent
encore se refermer un pourrissement du
conflit par un politique inflexible
pourraient ne faire aucun vainqueur pas
même le politique trop ou trop peu de
compromis pourrait nuire au compromis et
à la réforme tu es la réforme enfin on
observe aussi de la part des syndicats
qu'une action trop violente ou trop
longue pourrait être moins efficace et
devenir à terme contre-productive quant
aux Français dans leur ensemble il
semble embarquer dans un conflit entre
générations via une discrimination entre
les actifs d'un côté les retraités de
l'autre il ne reste qu'à espérer que ce
constat du tout ce piéger ne s'achève
pas dans une issue terrible du tous
perdants la réforme des retraites n'est
d'une triangulation équivoque pourrait
conduire le politique à ne pouvoir
sortir de l'ambiguïté qu'à son détriment
entraînant avec lui de nombreux déçus
[Musique]
on en parlait en début d'émission
vendredi 17 mars l'association
Solidarité nationale pour le handicap et
les militaires blessés organisent un
gala de charité pour soutenir des
projets au service du vivre ensemble
pour en parler de militaires Vincent
Dorival et Nicolas éteint alors pour
ceux qui n'étaient pas là en début
d'émission avec nous je le rappelle
Vincent de rival vous avez été blessé
dans l'exercice de vos fonctions et vous
Nicolas hit un vous êtes le père d'un
enfant trisomique alors à travers cette
soirée quel est le message que vous
souhaitez faire passer
de sensibiliser sensibiliser sur les
diffusion sur les différents thématiques
qui vont être abordées lors d'une table
ronde ce soir là donc à savoir les
militaires blessés et réinsertion
justement pour eux
il y a également donc tout ce qui est
inclusion que ce soit l'inclusion
l'insertion professionnelle des
personnes en situation de handicap mais
aussi l'éducation qui justement qui mène
à l'insertion professionnelle c'est
finalement c'est tous ces projets c'est
neuf projets qui seront représentés ce
soir là
parleront de ces trois thématiques
j'ai est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
parler c'est ça c'est l'association
ultra Ops que j'ai l'honneur de présider
qui a donc depuis 2018
elle a pour mission de du moins d'objet
en tout cas de de prendre des blessés
avec une dominante force spéciale mais
aussi des gens des transmissions des
pompiers de Paris du GIGN pour la
gendarmerie service de santé des armées
avec des infirmiers conserviers en
compagnie de combat
et les gens étrangères voilà l'idée
c'était de d'être le plus représentatif
possible de prendre ces gens qui ont été
blessés au combat pour la plupart
et de leur montrer qu'ils ont une
plus-value que leur blessure a une
plus-value et que ils sont encore en
capacité de faire de grandes choses et
du coup on les met en difficulté on fait
exprès
en les engageant sur des traversées de
désert en mode dégradé parce qu'on
avance avec un bivouac et l'idée voilà
c'est au fur et à mesure que qu'ils
enchaînent les kilomètres mais qui
puissent s'apercevoir qu'ils sont encore
en capacité de réaliser de grandes
choses du coup ils reprennent confiance
en eux et voilà c'est c'est à partir de
ce moment là où ils entrent dans dans ce
dans cette difficulté il tente de d'en
sortir et il faut qu'il reste sur cette
dynamique cette positivité et voilà donc
on a des gens aussi en syndrome pods
chromatique
qu'on diagnostique de de mieux en mieux
et de plus en plus malheureusement
voilà donc il se servent de cet
événement là pour rebondir c'est un
tremplin finalement
de réinsertion soit en unité ou soit à
la reconversion professionnelle un beau
projet en tout cas Nicolas hit un il y a
d'autres projets qui vont être proposés
aborder lors de ce gala est-ce que
pareil vous pouvez nous les présenter
Paris du projet que je représente
également
donc avec mon épouse on a créé il y a
deux ans l'association dans tes pas qui
qui a pour but de créer une petite école
pour des jeunes avec une déficience
intellectuelle j'ai 12 à 18 ans une
petite école innovante en fait qui
se placerait entre les IME les instituts
médicaux éducatifs et Les Ulis les
unités localisées d'inclusion scolaires
de façon à apporter justement à ces
jeunes
des apprentissages adaptés avec un
encadrement on va dire plus présent et
plus justement plus important pour
pouvoir vraiment individualiser les
apprentissages pour ces jeunes de façon
à les guider à les accompagner dans leur
projet de vie et leur donner les bons
outils pour une inclusion réussie
donc voilà c'est un des 9 projets qui
sera présenté il y a également d'autres
projets
un projet sur une ferme qui veut être
créée justement pour embaucher et faire
vivre des jeunes en situation de
handicap
justement dans un cadre
pleine nature avec un travail spécifique
mais justement dont ils sont capables de
faire de façon les épanouir avec le
contact des animaux dans d'autres tâches
voilà après d'autres projets encore liés
justement au militaires sur la
réservation par le sport
qui seront pris qui sont présentés ce
soir-là et alors ce gars de charité il
regroupe plusieurs associations vous
êtes une dizaine d'associations il me
semble c'était important d'avoir ces
nombreux acteurs là c'est l'union fait
la force sans quelque sorte
de montrer qu'on travaille ensemble
justement pour cette même cette même
problématique de façon à sensibiliser
les gens sur sur ce vivre ensemble sur
cette inclusion sur ces différentes
thématiques qu'on a abordées et donc
vous avez aussi de nombreux soutiens
puisqu'il y a vous avez la pluie du
ministère des personnes handicapées et
également de l'armée de l'air
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça signifie
pour vous de ben voilà d'être appuyé par
par des grands
ça montre que on fait partie de la même
société vous avez un côté donc
l'état-major de l'armée de l'air à côté
un
patronat du ministère de en charge de
handicap voilà donc ça montre finalement
qu'on fait partie de la même société
qu'on avance sur les mêmes
problématiques on a des réponses voilà
on travaille ensemble
c'est le meilleur exemple de de pour
montrer
une façon d'être inclusif et voilà dans
dans la société que finalement on
partage et ce pourquoi le l'idée
effectivement de de rassembler des gens
qui viennent de domaine différents mais
bon quand on parle du handicap
finalement on arrive à se retrouver et
avancer dans le dans le même sens et
vous avez également trois par un alors
il y a Thomas Lombard le directeur de du
général du Stade Français il y a Charles
Rodwell le député de la première
circonscription des Yvelines et Fabien
offrecheteur le maire de
Verneuil-sur-Seine vous avez pu échanger
avec eux et pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ont
décidé de soutenir ce gala de solidarité
je pense qu'ils sont sensibles justement
cette thématique et voilà ils veulent
ils veulent s'investir ils veulent
donner du crédit justement à notre
démarche et voilà nous aider justement à
faire connaître ces différents projets
et
à développer justement ce type
d'initiative
comment on commence à se passe pour
assister à la soirée tout le monde peut
venir ou
non c'est sur invitation en fait voilà
il y a des invitations qui ont été
lancées donc auprès de d'élus auprès
d'associations auprès d'entreprises
et en fait c'est vrai que l'objectif de
la soirée d'une part donc comme je vous
le disais c'est de sensibiliser
justement sur cette thématique mais
également de lever les fonds justement
pour les différents projets qui ont
besoin de soutien financier pour pour
pouvoir avancer sur leurs différents
projets et vous attendez combien de
personnes pour l'instant on espère
accueillir 200 personnes ce soir
et bien merci Vincent andorival et
Nicolas est un d'avoir répondu à nos
questions on va passer à un tout autre
sujet maintenant des mouettes retrouvées
mortes de la grippe aviaire sur
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines il y a
quelques semaines une situation
inquiétante pour de nombreux habitants
l'occasion pour nous de faire un point
sur l'influence à vierres dans le
département le reportage de Julien Leroy
des dizaines de mouettes retrouvées
mortes dans le bassin de la Sourderie à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux selon les
résultats d'analyses la grippe aviaire
H5 N1 est responsable de cette incidence
survenue fin janvier c'est qu'à isolé
n'inquiète pas la direction
départementale de la protection des
populations qui assure la surveillance
de toute la chaîne alimentaire du chant
à l'assiette aucun foyer de
contamination n'a été détecté chez les
producteurs de volailles yvelin le fait
que on sache que le virus circule chez
les oiseaux sauvages en Île-de-France et
dans les Yvelines a incité à encore plus
leur demander de de voilà d'être de plus
encore plus vigilant que habituellement
c'est éleveur sur la commune de Lognes
produit 3000 volailles sur son
exploitation de 35 hectares il cultive
l'alimentation de ses animaux et réalise
la battage lui-même ses oiseaux sont
confinés dans les bâtiments depuis fin
novembre 2022 le nouvel arrêté
préfectoral ce qu'il impose c'est moi
qui suis éleveur de canard c'est de
faire des prélèvements toutes les
semaines sur les canards parce que le
canard il est porteur sain et on voit
pas forcément quand les canards sont
malades
un poulet on voit qu'ils sont malades
parce qu'il meurent donc c'est rapide en
tant qu'elles veulent moi j'évite les
jardineries j'évite d'aller chez les
collègues j'évite de laisser rentrer les
gens chez moi donc même les vétérinaires
et tout j'aime bien voilà j'ai moins ils
viennent et mieux je me porte
l'agriculteur a décidé d'arrêter sa
production de palmipède pour se
consacrer un élevage moins contraignant
je vais développer des poules des races
anciennes donc du coup j'ai commandé des
poussins de race anciennes et donc là au
printemps comme on vend beaucoup de
poules à mettre dans les jardins et bah
du coup je vais remplacer les canards
par une production de rassent ancienne
voilà que je vais vendre pareil à la
ferme au détail des expérimentations
sont en cours pour la commercialisation
d'un vaccin sur les volailles qui
pourrait voir le jour à l'automne 2023
l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé
affirme en quel ce stade la transmission
à l'homme du virus est rare et peu
soutenu l'épidémie reste cependant sous
surveillance dans l'éventualité d'une
mutation plus agressive
l'association Les Amis du Vieux
Saint-Germain fête ses 100 ans cette
année à la pour but de valoriser le
patrimoine historique de la ville de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et pour en parler
avec nous ce soir son secrétaire général
Jean-Claude Peltier alors Jean-Claude
Pelletier vous nous l'avez un petit peu
rappelé en début d'émission mais quelle
est l'histoire en fait de cette
association parce qu'elle a été créée en
1923 est-ce que vous pouvez nous
rappeler son histoire alors c'est un
nommé Louis forest qui était un élu qui
a décidé en 1922 donc de lancer une
association dont la qui a été créé en
mars 1923 donc et qui a réuni beaucoup
de personnalités à l'époque
qui était en général des élus locaux
mais il y avait par exemple le faisait
partie de l'association
membre du comité le peintre Maurice
Denis qui est
le musée du prieuré
à Saint-Germain-en-Laye il y avait
Anatole France par exemple
donc des des hautes personnalités et qui
se sont lancés dans des dans deux
directions la première c'est vraiment
des études je dirais presque
d'archéologie
à Saint-Germain-en-Laye et dans les
environs et ils ont découvert un certain
nombre de choses et puis également de la
divulgué diffusion par des conférences
par des visites et
ils ont eu un succès une espérée
puisqu'ils sont arrivés très vite à 400
adhérents et
ceci a très bien marché jusqu'à la mort
de Louis forest malheureusement qui est
décédé assez rapidement et là ça a
commencé un peu à baisser il y a eu de
moins en moins de visites et beaucoup
moins d'adhérents et puis la guerre est
intervenue s'il y a eu du mal à
reprendre après la Seconde Guerre
mondiale et étant donné que dans les
années
60 que ça reprit avec en particulier la
participation de l'association à toute
une un projet
urbain la municipalité les a fait appel
à l'association pour essayer de d'aider
à classer des bâtiments et éviter qu'ils
deviennent l'objet de spéculation
immobilière
c'est toujours un peu le problème c'est
le moment on est en train de glorieuses
c'est le moment où il y avait beaucoup
de construction donc il y a eu ils ont
fait un gros travail à cette époque mais
la contrepartie c'est qu'il y avait
moins d'adhérents puisque c'était
vraiment des spécialistes qui épuisent
l'association avec plus d'adhérents
il y a eu des nouveaux présidents des
nouveaux présidents qui étaient
quelqu'un qui sortait du conseil
municipal qui et qui a dit il faut
relancer et qui a cherché à faire
plus moins peut-être de scientifiques et
plus de
je dirais de diffusion et alors on a eu
et participation aussi que les gens
participent à part le biais de visite
par de conférence
de voyage même donc des petit à petit
c'est remonté et on est maintenant on
n'a pas tout à fait rattrapé 1923 mais
nous sommes à 350 adhérents donc c'est
quelque chose qui est pas mal et nous
faisons donc tout un panel de
d'activités alors justement parlez-en
quels sont les activités un peu
marquantes de cette association
et un colloque chaque année bon un
colloque important qui fait venir des
intervenants renommés et qui ont un
sujet
qui peut être très variable mais
toujours lié à Saint-Germain-en-Laye
alors cette année sera sur quoi alors
cette année
Saint-Germain-en-Laye les 100 ans d'une
société savante et on fait intervenir
les sociétés savantes de la région
donc qui aura lieu au mois de mars c'est
normal s'entend après donc
ça fait partie de la fête pour
pour
un fil rouge toute l'année qui est le
centenaire et donc on a des conférences
donc une pas toute mais la majeure
partie sont consacrés aux années 20
alors pas uniquement à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye nous avons eu
je dirais la création enfin
le rail à Saint-Germain-en-Laye gare
Saint-Germain-en-Laye la ligne Paris
saint-germain-en-layette est la première
voie ferrée française alors là on n'est
pas dans le centenaire là on est presque
à 200 ans
mais ensuite nous avons alors des
conférences qui
présentent la France dans les années 20
avec un petit accent sur l'art quand
même l'art et la musique parce que c'est
très très important et puis nous avons
une conférence très simple très
importante c'est le centenaire du Bol
d'Or il se trouve que le premier Bol
d'Or a eu à Saint-Germain-en-Laye donc
il y aura une conférence au mois de juin
sur le Bol d'Or les 100 ans du Bol d'Or
et puis nous
nous avons en plus un certain nombre de
concerts auxquels nous emmenons nos
adhérents la Philharmonie
nous avons des visites et nous terminons
l'année par un grand concert
qui touche tout Saint-Germain-en-Laye
c'est-à-dire que ce sont les Amis du
Vieux Saint-Germain qui organise le
concert
ce concert il y a un cœur qui est le
cœur Saint Germain donc le cœur de la
paroisse Saint-Germain à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et l'orchestre et
l'orchestre de Saint-Germain qui est
récent qui a été créé il y a deux ou
trois ans et qui est très très bon
moitié professionnel moitié amateur donc
ceci mais en plus nous on est associé à
l'Université Libre de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye la municipalité
nous soutient et tout ceci a lieu au
Théâtre Alexandre Dumas de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye donc vous voyez on
est vraiment complètement
voilà et donc voilà si vous voulez en
gros les activités de cette année qui
sont liées au centenaire sinon nous
avons
chaque année de voyage un voyage en
France et un voyage à l'étranger alors
cette année je crois qu'il y en a un en
Haute-Marne et du coup à l'étranger ce
sera en Italie on a un peu pris par le
temps est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
parler juste rapidement alors pour la
Haute-Marne si vous voulez
quand on parle de la Haute-Marne les
gens en général nous dit tiens il y a
pourtant il y a des choses
extraordinaires en Haute-Marne je dirais
ne serait-ce que colomber les deux
églises qui est quand même a lieu
symbolique mais il y a la ville de
Londres par exemple et puis
si vous voulez un certain nombre à
Chaumont il y a des choses aux gens etc
enfin vous avez
des lieux qui sont extrêmement
intéressants et alors l'Italie vous
allez où alors l'Italie ce sera Raven
puis les villas palladiennes avec un
petit passage quand même à Padoue il y a
une chapelle absolument magnifique avec
des fresques du gel auto donc si vous
voulez
tout ceci prévue en septembre donc l'an
prochain on est déjà sur la préparation
des voyages de l'an prochain parce que
c'est évident qu'on prend un peu
d'avance merci beaucoup Jean-Claude
Pelletier d'avoir accepté notre
invitation du coup je le rappelle vous
êtes le secrétaire général de
l'association Les Amis de Saint-Germain
je vous souhaite du vieux Saint-Germain
alors faut faire attention on nous
appelle les vieux singes
on va éviter en tout cas je vous
souhaite un joyeux centenaire du coup
merci beaucoup allez c'est l'heure
maintenant de passer à notre page
loisirs
[Musique]
et on commence cette page loisir par une
magnifique exposition réunissant deux
grands photographes Jacques Henry
l'Artigue et André kerese elle s'est
ouverte hier à l'espace riche au de
Versailles nous avons demandé un autre
photographe Claude de nous présenter
cette exposition regardez
[Musique]
nous sommes heureux de pouvoir vous
parler de d'une exposition très
intéressante qui se déroule à l'heure
actuelle à l'espace Richaud à Versailles
qui concerne deux grands photographes de
un français et roumain tous les deux
sont nés dans les années
1894 et ils sont décédés donc en 60 en
86 1 85 et l'autre à 86 pour Jacques
Henri Lartigue Jacques Henri garrigue on
connaît c'était c'est lui qui avait fait
la photo officielle de Giscard d'Estaing
que nous avons derrière
et kerese donc c'est un personnage
d'origine roumaine qui lui était plutôt
de conditions modeste contrairement à
Jacques Henri Lartigue qui était d'une
famille de grands bourgeois d'ailleurs
dans les photos que nous vous présentons
on verra que Jacques-Henri l'Artigue un
de ces quelqu'un de sa famille fabriqué
des comment s'appelle des avions et il
s'est initié essayer de s'envoler avec
des avions qui étaient tirés par des
hommes André cartel est venu en France
en 1936 entre les deux guerres et il a
vécu une période en France ils étaient
d'ailleurs amis très proches avec
Jacques-André lactique il y en a un qui
s'est initié au journalisme qui était
André kertez et
Jacques Henri Lartigue lui sur la photo
plus de monde la vie intime de sa
famille et il a montré quand même de
très très belles choses et des très
beaux portraits des gens de sa famille
cette exposition se déroule à l'espace
Richaud dans un cadre assez très
versaillé je dirais et il est
intéressant pour vous d'aller voir cette
exposition dans lequel vous pourrez voir
des tirages d'origine qui ont été prêtés
par la Fondation l'Artigue et aussi de
cartes thèse mais qui lui faisait des
photos beaucoup plus petites parce que
il n'avait pas les mêmes moyens que
Monsieur l'Artigue les deux ont été
exposés au moment de New York à des
périodes un peu différentes parce que
côté des gens qui étaient très proches
et qui se sont découverts bien que leur
niveau social était complètement
différent comme vous pouvez voir sur
cette image donc là nous avons une image
de Jacques Henri Lartigue qui avait
photographié et Sacha Guitry quand on
connaît Sacha Guipry qui était dans
l'excessif etc donc on voit bien comment
il l'avait habillé comme disait quartier
Bresson qu'a connu André kerese
photographié c'est voir ce que les
autres ne voient pas et aussi bien
Jacques Henri l'Artigue que André kerese
ont su dénoter dans leur photographie si
vous voulez
quelque chose de très particulier avant
de terminer je voudrais m'arrêter sur
une photo que j'ai prise donc lors de la
visite de cette exposition ou à partir
de la photo qui était exposée il y avait
un reflet qui rentrait dans la photo et
ça me permet de rajouter une note
personnelle à cette photo que je trouve
très intéressante puisque quand vous
regardez cette photo si vous voulez vous
voyez l'accueil chaleureux
que vous avez dans cette maison et le
fait de rajouter cette glace si vous
voulez cette cette fenêtre si vous
voulez apporter une touche personnelle
et peut-être plus actuelle
[Musique]
et vous pourrez voir cette exposition
jusqu'au 14 mai prochain et nous avons
été rejoint au plateau par Régine rallès
bonsoir bonsoir alors c'est vous qui
prenez en main le quiz ce soir c'est ça
vous allez nous challenger sur la
royauté dans les Yvelines les rois de
France qui ont été deux passages dans
les Yvelines exactement j'espère que
vous êtes prêtes on verra mais avant
tout ça on va parler d'un concept
original savez-vous qu'il est possible
de prendre un café en savourant sa tasse
c'est une idée insolite créée par un
couple d'entrepreneurs de la commune de
Janville dans le nord des Yvelines la
tasse est faite d'un biscuit sec et d'un
nappage au chocolat Julien Leroy est
parti à la rencontre de Kevin et Julie
Couvet et de leur atelier de production
regardée dans le village de jambes ville
dans les Yvelines se cache une fabrique
bien particulière au fond de son garage
Kevin couvert est en pleine production
bon on va bienvenu dans l'atelier
bienvenue chez Arduino je vais vous
faire visiter avec son épouse Julie
l'entrepreneur de 35 ans a fondé
l'entreprise en novembre 2022 un concept
original de tasse comestible pour le
café faites un biscuit sec et d'un
glaçage chocolat bien que ses cookies
shots exigent sur les réseaux sociaux
qui viennent Couvet à l'idée d'en faire
un produit cadeau et événementiel on a
fait une formation accélérée en
biscuiterie pour pouvoir avoir tous les
tous les bonnes toutes les bonnes
pratiques on a travaillé plusieurs mois
sur la recette et du coup il a fallu la
faire goûter il a fallu attester tester
la durabilité aussi pour pouvoir valider
notre date de consommation optimum du
coup je glace les tasses au chocolat
noir et ça leur permet en fait d'être
étanche ça veut dire que quand on va
mettre une boisson chaude dedans ça va
pas ça va pas fuir le chocolat va garder
la le liquide dans la tasse les produits
sont élaborés en partie avec des
matières premières locales farine des
moulins de Versailles et chocolat noir
Grand Cru 64% d’ardric court moins votre
produit a un impact carbone élevé mieux
c'est aujourd'hui c'est carrément le
sens de l'histoire déjà la tasse on la
mange donc on la jette pas la forme
n'utilise pas d'eau il y a une démarche
écologique mais elle prend tout son sens
quand on se déplace dans les entreprise
quand on va chez les gens et qu'on fait
de l'événementiel parce que là du coup
on arrive sans poubelle on repart sans
poubelle suite à sa récente
médiatisation l'entreprise familiale a
vu ses ventes se multiplier par 3 le
couple confectionne désormais 600 tasses
quotidiennement sur 3 jours de
production hebdomadaire chaque étape est
artisanale il y a aucune étape mécanique
donc tout est fait à la main dans notre
atelier 100% made in France de
l'emballage aux ingrédients depuis son
lancement l'atelier arzino a créé 30000
tasses courant mars 2023 le couple
d'entrepreneurs lancera deux gammes
salées façon verrines pour les apéritifs
en attendant vous pouvez croquer à
belles dents dans votre café
alors est-ce que ça vous donne envie de
tester Gabriel et Régine ah oui oui
ça vous a donné faim oui ça nous donne
enfin surtout à cette heure là je pense
manger tout de A à Z c'est je pense
qu'on rêve oui en tout cas c'est en
plateau là
en tout cas Julien le roi nous a ramené
deux tasses mais je crois qu'il en a
mangé une et on a donné une autre à un
de nos collègues Grégory canalet le
chanceux voilà
sur place allez on poursuit cette page
loisirs avec vos idées de sortie Gabriel
alors à l'approche des vacances
scolaires vous avez un petit peu étendu
qu'est-ce que vous nous avez prévu ce
soir oui cette semaine matin de j'ai
élargi les idées de sortie pour les
vacances scolaires et on commence tout
de suite avec du théâtre à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et une pièce
familiale pister les créatures
fabuleuses la pièce vous plonge tout
droit dans une forêt peuplée d'animaux
et de végétaux l'objectif invité les
spectateurs à écouter et déchiffrer les
énigmes des êtres vivants c'est
d'ailleurs ce que va faire la comédienne
sur scène au travers des traces laissées
par les animaux elle va découvrir
l'histoire que celle-ci raconte une
pièce hommage donc à la beauté du vivant
inspiré par une conférence du philosophe
Baptiste Morisot la pièce se joue
jusqu'à samedi et alors Gabriel vous
avez un autre rendez-vous à nos proposés
ce weekend puisqu'il s'achève bientôt
oui et vous avez jusqu'à dimanche pour
profiter de l'exposition Louis XV
passion d'un roi au château de
Versailles pour ces dernières journées
d'ouverture l'exposition se décline en
nocturne au total 400 œuvres inédites du
monde entier ces œuvres permettent de
comprendre la complexité de l'homme
derrière le monarque mais également de
comprendre le style unique de son règne
et les passions de celui qui est le seul
roi de France à avoir commencé sa ville
là où il l'a terminé au château de
Versailles alors l'exposition elle a
déjà accueilli plus de 200 000 personnes
et alors pour les vacances scolaires
vous nous proposez des animations la
semaine prochaine oui du 18 février au 4
mars le musée de la ville de sont un en
Yvelines proposent différents ateliers
parmi eux une visite de l'exposition
Space Age et des ateliers sur la
thématique de l'espace ou encore des
ateliers autour du design et des formes
et des couleurs mais aussi des jeux de
tri de classement ou encore de puzzle
certains ateliers sont accessibles des 4
ans la réservation est conseillée elle
peut se faire au 01 34 52 28 80 ou sur
le site
kiosque.sky.fr et les tarifs Mathilde
sont compris entre 2 et 3 euros alors de
quoi
occuper vos enfants pendant les vacances
d'autres villes proposent aussi des
animations pour les vacances c'est
notamment le cas de Guyancourt
exactement Guyancourt avec le phare
jeunesse qui propose pendant les deux
semaines de vacances de nombreuses
activités pour les 15 25 ans au
programme des activités culturelles
sportives et divertissantes pour vous
donner un petit aperçu des activités il
y aura une sortie à Paris de l'escalade
et même du cinéma les jeunes pourront
également découvrir les coulisses de la
production TV de l'émission masque
singer si vous êtes intéressé vous devez
vous inscrire avant le 17 février donc
demain si vous habitez une des communes
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines vous pouvez
consulter directement les sites internet
de vos villes alors parce qu'il en faut
aussi pour les grands Gabriels on
poursuit avec une exposition photo oui
une exposition à photos à la
Bibliothèque Universitaire de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines dans
l'exposition des lumières et des ombres
le photographe François belfontaine nous
fait redécouvrir Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines en noir et blanc au travers
d'une dizaine de clichés ce sont des
instants de nombreux instants de vie
pardon qui sont capturés dans cette
exposition et vous avez une dernière
idée de sortie Gabriel oui Mathilde si
vous vivez dans les alentours des
Mureaux sachez que le café bar la carte
à jouer a ouvert ses portes cette
semaine il s'agit d'un café je situais
au centre-ville de quoi passer un moment
convivial en famille ou entre amis
pendant les vacances par exemple merci
beaucoup Gabriel alors Régine je sais
pas est-ce qu'il y a une idée de sortie
qui vous a tenté plus qu'une autre
l'exposition Louis XV
moi je pense plutôt pour l'exposition
photo en noir et blanc sur sur
l'histoire de 50 ans en Yvelines
on continue de vous donner des idées de
sortie dans les Yvelines avec une autre
exposition je vous fais un petit teasing
dans cette exposition vous devrez vous
plonger dans l'histoire en mérovingienne
en incarnant un héros fictif sur votre
Smartphone vous devrez ainsi prendre des
décisions cruciales pour votre
personnage est-ce que dit comme ça ça
vous tente un peu Régine et Gabriel je
suis assez curieuse de moi en tout cas
c'est le concept imaginé par le Musée
d'archéologie nationale de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye Julien Leroy vous
présente l'exposition le monde de
clovisé
son nom est arrivé plusieurs fois
jusqu'à mon oreille jouer un héros de
l'époque mérovingienne lors d'une
exposition c'est l'expérience immersive
proposée dans le monde de Clovis au
Musée d'archéologie nationale de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye pour découvrir
l'époque du premier Moyen-Âge le public
est invité à interpréter un personnage
fictif via son smartphone l'énergie
candarchius la bile bâtild la courageuse
Geneviève ou l'intelligence Médard on a
tout à fait voulu s'inspirer des codes
du jeu de rôle du jeu vidéo des escape
game pour attirer un public un peu plus
jeune par rapport à celui qu'on a
l'habitude de d'accueillir ici au Musée
d'archéologie nationale
ce public voilà les adolescents les
jeunes adultes c'est un public qui de
manière générale fréquente moins les
musées parce qu'il est très exigeant il
a besoin peut-être aussi qu'on s'adapte
à ses attentes le visiteur choisit les
différentes étapes de la naissance à la
mort de son personnage point de prestige
et de richesse sont gagnés en fonction
de la pertinence des réponses les objets
exposés illustrent l'histoire du héros
incarné comme ce dilemme crucial dans
l'existence de Médard faut que je fasse
un choix un choix de vie est-ce que je
veux rester à la cour avec ben voilà le
grand monde on illustre ça avec les
bijoux de la reine aregonde ou est-ce
que je veux plutôt suivre le destin de
la reine bah tilde dont la tunique de
moniale est présentée juste à côté et
est-ce que je veux entrer au monastère
c'est une exposition qui est c'est bien
expliqué et aussi ce qui est bien c'est
qu'on peut choisir son personnage et
c'est un peu nous le le personnage pour
les adultes et bah il y avait les textes
sont suffisamment clairs et suffisamment
court pour que ça soit agréable c'est
romerovingiens attire environ 1000
visiteurs chaque week-end le monde de
Clovis est à retrouver jusqu'au 22 mai
2023 au Musée d'archéologie nationale de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye
Clovis premier roi de France c'est ce
qui vous inspiré Régine pour préparer ce
quiz sur la royauté dans les Yvelines
c'est tellement ça nous a tous inspiré
nous tous les journalistes de la
rédaction on vous a contact concocté
pardon un quiz sur la royauté dans les
Yvelines alors est-ce que vous êtes
prêtes oui allez est-ce qu'on peut et
d'ailleurs ceux qui nous regardent
également à travers les réseaux sociaux
vous pouvez tenter de répondre à ce quiz
alors la première question porte sur
Saint-Germain allez on en a parlé tout à
l'heure à votre avis quel roi naît au
château de Saint-Germain-en-Laye
alors là
je le savais mais je sais plus
il me semble c'est peut-être un louis
mais alors lequel je sais plus alors la
réponse c'est Louis XIV qui est né au
château de Saint-Germain-en-Laye en 1638
et voilà
c'est pas grave on va passer à la
question suivante à votre avis quel
souverain ou souveraine à ses journées
dans le département à plusieurs reprises
il y en a plusieurs
alors est-ce que vous voulez un petit
indice
bah il y a c'est le château de
Versailles donc Louis XIV alors là on se
suit plutôt au 20e siècle
Louis XVI
oui 17 et 18
donc c'est Elisabeth II Elizabeth donc
voilà donc elle est venue donc pour
information elle est venue en 1948 à
l'Auberge de la Moutière à
Montfort-l'Amaury elle est venue aussi
en 1957 en tant que Rennes au château de
Versailles et à flanc pour faire une
visite d'ailleurs la visite de Renault
et en 1972 elle est de nouveau venue au
château de Versailles et cette fois-ci
elle a été accueillie par le président
Georges Pompidou pour un dîner
bon les filles 0-0
et je pense que la question 3 ça va un
petit peu se corser donc c'est la
suivante Marie-Antoinette n'aimait pas
se rendre dans ce château Louis XVI son
cher et tendre lui offre un lieu rien
que pour elle de quoi parlons-nous
[Musique]
quel quel lieu Louis XVI a-t-il offert
un mari Antoinette et c'était une
surprise
alors c'est la laiterie de la reine au
Château de Rambouillet ça vous parle oui
donc voilà il met pas se rendre au
château de Rambouillet et pour
l'amadouer donc son époux le roi lui a
fait la surprise parce que apparemment à
l'époque c'était quelque chose qui était
en vogue bon quatrième question les
filles c'est ce que là ça devrait aller
alors en 1994 il y a eu une soirée
organisée au château de Versailles donc
pour les enfants qui sont maltraités
donc c'était une soirée caritative il y
a une princesse qui était invitée de qui
par le ton
vous avez dit en quelle année en 1994
Lady Diana
[Rires]
la princesse de Galles donc Lady Diana
Lady Diana en anglais super merci Régine
pour ce quiz donc voilà
ça fera un point pour celles qui détient
la licence d'histoire
merci beaucoup Régine en tout cas on en
apprend toujours grâce à ses couilles
j'espère que vous aussi chez vous vous
en apprenez un peu plus sur l'histoire
des Yvelines allez c'est bientôt la fin
de cette émission mais juste avant de se
quitter jetons un dernier coup d'oeil à
la météo de demain
[Musique]
matin le ciel sera nuageux sur
l'ensemble du département au niveau des
températures il fera environ 11 degrés
du côté de Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan et
10 degrés dans le secteur de Versailles
et Rambouillet dans l'après-midi
prévoyait quelques averses à
Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans et Versailles
seul Rambouillet devrait rester au sexe
selon Météo France côté et température
comptait environ 14 degrés dans le
secteur de Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan et
13 degrés à Versailles et Rambouillet et
pour ce week-end quel temps fera-t-il
Gabriel et bien un temps plutôt agréable
Mathilde pour ce week-end dans la
matinée les températures seront
comprises entre 9 et 10 degrés sur le
territoire côté ciel malgré les nuages
au nord des éclaircies sont à prévoir
dans la partie sud du département
l'après-midi même tendance il faut il
fera 12 degrés à Versailles et
Rambouillet et 13 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan dimanche des
éclaircisse seront présentes sur tout le
département dans la matinée qu'on te dit
degrés à Versailles Houdan et
Rambouillet et 11 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie l'après-midi les
températures restent les mêmes elles
seront comprises entre 10 et 11 degrés
merci beaucoup Gabriel alors c'est le
début des vacances scolaires d'hiver et
les et pour les élèves de la région
parisienne alors attention si vous avez
prévu de prendre la route quelles sont
les prévisions Bison Futé Gabriel oui en
ce début de vacances d'hiver attention
si vous avez prévu de prendre la route
ce weekend quelques perturbations sont à
prévoir vendredi Bison Futé voient
orange dans le sens des départs en
Île-de-France il est conseillé de
quitter ou de traverser la région avant
11h c'est vers dans le sens des retours
samedi le trafic devrait s'améliorer en
Île-de-France mais les conditions de
circulation seront très difficiles si
vous vous rendez vers les sites station
de ski dans les Alpes les Vosges ou le
Jura c'est rouge dans une grande partie
et dans la grande partie Est de la
France et orange dans le sens des
retours en région Auvergne Rhône-Alpes
et enfin dimanche tout rentre dans
l'ordre Bison Futé prévoit vers en
Île-de-France et sur l'ensemble du
territoire dans les deux sens de
circulation alors il faudra s'armer de
patience pour la journée de samedi merci
beaucoup Gabriel c'est la fin de cette
émission merci pour votre fidélité je
vous souhaite une bonne soirée sur TV 78
et de bonnes vacances pour les plus
chanceux prenez soin de vous
[Musique]